un moulin du 13ème siècle au charme
indiscutable mais au toit éventré à
l'intérieur l'ampleur des travaux est
colossal ça va être typiquement la
couverture les éléments de charpente
puisqu'il soutiennent la couverture ça
va être les enduits extérieurs nous on a
demandé aussi à mettre toute la partie
fermeture parce qu'elle est absolument
pas aux normes vous voyez ces grandes
fenêtres
l'architecte des bâtiments de France ne
veut pas de ça couper des seuls travaux
extérieurs 500.000 euros le bâtiment
construit sur la Creuse sa fesse d'un
millimètre par an alors il faut d'abord
mettre à sec le moulin et injecter du
béton en sous-oeuvre avant de colmater
les fissures et de poursuivre la
consolidation
et ici vous avez la chambre d'eau
l'ancienne usine hydroélectrique
fonctionnera à nouveau seule condition
le changement des turbines et la mise en
conformité écologique de la rivière
encore une facture
1,4 millions d'euros c'était quand même
un peu de la conscience et je m'en suis
rendu compte après quand on commence à
faire les premiers chiffrages et qu'on
se rend compte que c'est voilà que c'est
c'est déraisonnable mais bon c'est trop
tard alors deux ans après l'achat le
coup de pouce de la mission Berne et le
bienvenu entre 50000 et 300.000 euros
d'aide selon le succès du Loto du
patrimoine pour préserver ce bâtiment
mémoire de la commune on se baignait
dans la rivière on pêchait dans la
rivière on avait une fête foraine ici le
15 août j'étais un lieu de d'animation
de rencontres les amoureux viennent là
voilà c'est et puis il y a du calme
c'est un endroit de ressourcement aussi
la somme exacte octroyée par la Mission
Berne sera connue en décembre